Hello, and welcome to
the Developer Show.
This is your TL;DR. Today, we're
open-sourcing three new hash
function
implementations-- faster,
data-parallel versions
of SipHash, a fast,
cryptographically strong
pseudorandom function,
and the entirely
new HighwayHash,
which reaches even higher speeds
thanks to the data parallel
features of modern computers.
Check out the post for more
info and the GitHub link.
Learn how to build your
own recommendation engine
using machine learning on Google
Compute Engine with this post
from the Google
Cloud Platform team.
Want to know why your
application is slow?
Cloud Trace for Google
Cloud Platform can help.
Today, we're adding more
features and functionality,
including automatic
tracing and performance
analysis for all App Engine
projects and latency shift
detection.
As always, the post has more.
Add-ons run inside Google
Sheets, Docs, and Forms.
Check out this post for
five simple design tips
to help make your add-on
a pleasure to use.
And don't worry if
you're not an artist.
These are basic concepts
that anyone can apply.
Optimizing retention before
investing in acquisition
and retaining users with
step-by-step engagement
are concepts that come
from the world of games.
Learn how you can use
these tips and insights
from successful game
developers in your app
with this post from Google Play.
We've redesigned our Developer
Program Policy Center
to communicate our
policies with greater
transparency and clarity.
From making it easier to
self-correct minor violations
in minutes using the
app publishing status
feature to improving our
policy communication,
the new Policy Center is
part of our ongoing effort
to improve the
developer experience.
We recently invited Mobile
World Congress attendees
into the National Art
Museum of Catalonia
with Tango developer kits loaded
with GuidiGO, a museum tour
app, and Glympse, a
location-sharing app,
to experience augmented
reality and indoor navigation
for themselves, and
it was really cool.
Check out the post
for more details
and a video of the experience.
Whitfield Diffie and
Martin E. Hellman
have won the 2015 ACM
Turing Award, commonly known
as the Nobel Prize of computing.
Their 1976 paper entitled "New
Directions in Cryptography"
introduced public-key
encryption,
which is a
foundational technology
for the commercial
World Wide Web.
That's your TL;DR for this week.
Make sure to subscribe to this
channel for developers show
interviews, AskDevShow
responses, and more.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.
Hey!
Remember when I was at the
International Women's Day event
a couple weeks ago?
It was awesome.
Here's another
interview and a link
to check out more
events and ways to get
involved with Women Techmakers.